[MUSIC]
Hello everyone,
welcome to the Stanford Graduate School
of Business online information section.
My name is Stephanie Witlin and
I'm a member of the MBA admissions office.
I'm excited to spend the next 60 minutes
with you talking about the MBA experience,
the admissions process and
answering your questions.
You'll also have a chance to meet
a couple of our current students and
ask them about their
experience here on campus.
So, let's begin.
Let's start by having each of you
briefly introduce yourselves and
talk a little bit about your backgrounds.
What were doing before business school and
what your goals are after you graduate.
I'll start with you, Aminash.
>> Thanks Stephanie,
my name is Animish Agurwal.
I'm a second-year student at the GSB.
I grew up in where I spent
the first 18 years of my life.
I did my undergrad from Delhi,
and post graduation I worked with
a management consulting firm in New Delhi
for about one-and-a-half years.
And then spent about two-and-a-half
years in Mumbai working for
a private equity firm.
Post graduation I plan
to be investing broadly.
>> Very good, thank you.
And Sushma Da.
>> I'm Sushma Da, I'm from Hyderabad.
Again spent first 18 years
of my life in Hyderabad,
then went to IDE Madras for engineering.
After IDE, I joined Unilever in
Mumbai as a management trainee.
I worked there for about three and
a half years when I got into GSB.
My goal for
getting into GSB was to, actually,
transition from consumer goods background
to consumer tech product management.
So before joining GSB, I did a couple
of internships in this space.
>> Okay, great, thank you both.
Now let's answer some
questions from our audience.
The first question we'll start with is,
what's the best way to prepare
to get the most out of Stanford if
I'm fortunate enough to be admitted?
>> Okay, I can take that one.
I think GSB's a place where you can,
fortunately, do everything.
But what I realized spending time
here is you can do everything here,
but not at the same time.
So what I would encourage all of you
to think through is what are the two,
three main things you plan to
achieve at the business school?
And keep that top of mind.
And as you evaluate that portion it is
at the GSB keeping that lens in mind.
So that when you walk
out of GSB at the end of
two years you don't feel like you've not
achieved what you came in thinking about.
>> Great, thanks.
>> Totally agree with what Animesh said.
In addition to that, life's going to
get real hectic once you come here.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I kind of work till the end of July,
I barely took any break,
don't make that mistake.
I would say, take a couple of months off
and spend time with your loved ones.
Because you're not going to see
them very often once you come here.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So that's my advice.
>> Great, thank you both.
The next question, when is the best
time to apply in your career trajectory?
And I'll take this one from
an admissions perspective.
You can add any color if you'd like.
So If you think about it from
an admissions perspective,
when you apply is completely irrelevant.
We admit candidates who are just
graduating from college,
so we admit individuals
who are college seniors.
And we also have individuals
who have at least a decade or
two of work experience in
every class every year.
So it can run the whole gambit
in terms of work experience.
I think it's important for you to
think about what makes sense for you.
So when is the right time for
you rather than how
we will evaluate the number of
years of work experience you have.
Do you guys have anything to add there?
>> And you covered it all.
>> Okay, very good.
The next question, what is
the biggest surprise you experienced
as you began your Stanford MBA journey?
>> I can take that.
I think the biggest surprise for me was
the feedback culture that existed here.
Especially, the certain courses which
we do in the very first quarter.
It gives us a good taste into
how much feedback is valued and
how much people are eager to
act upon the feedback they get.
It was something very new to me.
And the second thing which was surprising
to me is the sheer number of events that
were there for people with all kinds
of references for socializing.
There's no one way to do GSB experience.
There is so much support and
resources provided to help
everybody realize their GSB social life,
that they want it to be.
That was a pleasant surprise, I would say.
Very good, yeah.
>> I think in terms of academic experience
the class environment here encourages and
appreciates active participation
from all students.
So, I think coming from
a background where in a classroom
environment you're not used to sharing
those many experiences or views.
It was important to appreciate that is
the culture that wants you to share
your views and experience in the class.
>> Yeah, very open and honest feedback
you'll get, whether you want it or
not, right?
[LAUGH] Are there specific admissions
requirements for international students?
I'll add my take to this,
and that is, explicitly, no.
One of the requirements that we do
ask of international candidates,
if you have attended
a university where the primary
language of instruction was not
in English, we do require the.
We evaluate all candidates based on
the same three criteria as I discussed in
the video, intellectual vitality,
demonstrated leadership potential,
and personal qualities and contributions.
So all candidates are evaluated, equally.
The next question, what is life like
at the GSB as an international student?
>> I think GSB is an environment where
you have a lot of diversity in as many
aspects as you can think of.
And as international students,
I'm in a class with international
students from more than 60 countries.
And, I think, everybody comes
up with their own background,
own way in which they grew up.
And it's.
I have found it, personally, very
fascinating to just appreciate the fact
that how different people here look at
life or what motivates them, personally.
I think, for
some of us who have not grown up in
a culture with a lot diversity,
it's really good to appreciate how
people think about different things,
both in personal life and academically.
And [INAUDIBLE] I really
appreciated the American way of
looking at both academic and
non-academic things.
And how or what students from other
countries bring to the table.
>> For you, anything?
>> I think, I'm really impressed by
the kind of resources that exist for
international students.
I'm an international student that
has never lived in the US before.
I've lived all my life in
India before moving here.
But I found so much support all around me.
Because, like I mentioned in my
previous answer, there are so
many resources available to socialize
the way you want to socialize.
Mingling with other like minded people.
I currently work in the Students'
Association International Committee.
We put in a lot of thought to actually
incorporate all of the major international
events in Stanford life.
We recently, both of us together,
organized a Diwali party,
which was a big hit,
which was attended by almost.
People from all the other
nationalities as well.
Similarly, there is so much happening
with different identity clubs that
are there at GSP with
Latin America Student Association.
There's a Business of India
club which [INAUDIBLE] heads.
There's an Africa Business Club, there is
a Hispanic Students Business Association.
So there are so many places where
you get a lot of support
career-wise as well as socially.
So that's a great thing at JSB for
international students according to me.
>> Okay, great.
Thank you.
The next question I'll address as well,
which is, how do I craft a good essay?
[LAUGH] It's a popular question.
What I will say,
as you think about writing your essay,
it's important that you
use your authentic voice.
First and foremost what we're trying
to identify when we read your essay
is not only what matters most to you,
but explicitly why.
We want to understand your core values,
we want to hear from your perspectives,
your inner voice, what's important to you.
And I would say that it's not
necessarily a crafting of your essay
as much as it is being authentic and
true to yourself and
being able to convey that in
a clear manner in the essay.
You guys have anything to add there?
>> I think, I would just like to
reiterate, it's not a place you just
show your strength, and I would encourage
all of you to be authentic, and
these are some things that the GSB
community prides itself in.
So it's a good way to show
that through your essays.
>> Yeah, I would also like to add
that it's not an individual exercise.
I think it's a team effort.
I personally ran my essay by,
like, my closest friends and
colleagues and family, some of them.
So it was really useful to take input
of people who know you very well.
>> Yes, yeah.
>> To add a lot of color to your essay.
>> Yeah,
we often will say it is helpful to get
perspective from those who
know you incredibly well, and
when they read your essay,
that it sounds like you and only you.
>> Yeah.
>> The next question is how
did you finance your MBA?
Is it affordable for
the average Indian person?
And then I'll address some of
the questions regarding financial aid and
scholarships.
>> So I personally used a mix
of three different sources.
And a small part of it was
my own personal savings from
the job I did before business school.
The second major part was the financial
aid that I received from the school, and
the third part was the student loan that
is available to all students
that apply to the GSP.
So I think these are the three sources
that helped me finance my MBA and
to the cogent of it being affordable.
I come from a middle-class family, and
I think these three sources combine, like,
put you in a comfortable
position to do this MBA.
>> In my case, I am a recipient
of Reliance Dhirubhi Fellowship
which covered a majority of my expenses.
Apart from that,
I also used some of my savings from before
GSP as well as some family support.
>> Okay yeah.
Yes we do offer
a Reliance Dhirubhai Fellowship for
Indian citizens who can benefit from
two years of nearly full-time tuition.
So that scholarship, that fellowship
is available to all candidates.
Who are citizens of India.
Did you consider any graduate
programs in India and
why did you decide to come to the US for
your MBA?
>> I actually did not consider
other MBA programs in India,
I really liked the job, at which I
got through an internship that I did
it in my third year
while I was in college.
I wanted to walk before I do my MBA and
I was particularly fascinated
by an MBA in the US
when I saw some of my seniors in college
that I really look up to go that way.
And hearing from their experiences about
doing an MBA from a school like Stanford,
I understood the global perspective and
the kind of diverse experience we
get in an MBA school in the US.
And that to, having worked for a couple
of years before doing an MBA is really
valuable and it's very different
from doing an MBA in India.
I have a lot fo friends who
have done MBA in India and
they all have great careers I
have nothing against it but
I just feel like a US MBA is pretty
diverse, and it's a great life experience.
>> Okay, great.
>> I think in addition
to global perspective,
I think it also encourages
you to think of the cohort.
The cohort here, as I said, comes from
more than 60 different countries,
have varying level of work experience.
And I think that sort of diversity's
very difficult to replicate in an Indian
graduate school.
So I think that is one factor
that should help for me.
>> Okay, okay.
Moving along,
we'll go to the next question.
Can you talk about some
of your favorite classes?
You probably have one to share about.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And professors?
>> Sure, so I am just rushing
from a touchy feeling class.
I've just concluded my touchy
feely course this quarter.
Which was a life changing experience,
at the cost of sounding cliched,
but it's undoubtedly the best
experience at GSB so far.
Second, there are a lot of other great
classes, and particularly in Western
technology, so I do a lot of courses
in technology and entrepreneurship.
So there is a great course
called Electronic Business,
which is in the first year, then there's
another great course of Building and
Managing Seamless Organization,
which is a very practical course.
And you get to listen to some of the
prominent sales leaders in the industry.
There are several other courses for
people interested in entrepreneurship
like Startup Garage,
where you can start from the scratch,
from idea phase to execution phase.
A lot of people who are into
entrepreneurship really liked the class.
Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, I think for me the classes
which are related to communication or
matching difficult
conversations have stood out.
And one class that comes to mind
is managing growing enterprises by
Joel Peterson who is
the chairman of Jet Blue.
And that class basically takes about how
do you have difficult conversations with
the board.
How do you fire someone?
How do you give feedback to an employee
who has not been performing well?
So, some of these conversations we
will face at all phases of our life.
and just practicing them in our risk-free
environment is something that I
valued a lot.
>> Yeah.
Yeah I find oftentimes I talk to students
also about, or perspective candidates
about leadership labs which addresses
a lot of those same questions.
What do you do if you
have to fire someone?
>> Yes.
>> How do you handle difficult
conversations?
So you'll get lots of practice on that.
The next question is what percent of your
coursework is theory
versus hands-on learning?
Do you guys want to share a little bit
about what your perspective has been, or
experience in the classroom
as far as that goes?
I think it would be hard to
put a percentage value to it.
But I would say most of
the learning here is experiential,
and sort of working in groups or
teams to basically work that through.
For example, even in the first quarter,
we start with something called lead laps,
in which you have a cohort of six students
who basically give feedback to each other
every week on what about you
encourages me to follow you?
It's a very simple question.
But just the fact that you hear how
your actions land on different people in
a small cohort week
after week just sort of,
it's a good lab to put yourself through.
I think some of these activities where
you are either interacting with different
people or
doing it hands-on on a software or
on a lab just makes the learning process
much more interactive and much more fun.
So I would say most of my learning has
been experiential of working in teams.
Having said that, some of the courses
which require critical work,
like accounting and stuff, would be there.
And I think that's the best way
to learn some of those courses.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, yeah, so it's a mix of both.
There is a good number of courses
which are heavily theoretical.
And there's equal number of courses which
are experiential and practical in nature.
At the risk of sounding repetitive,
touchy, feely is very practical.
There's little to no
theory involved in it.
And similarly,
is like one out of a class, but
four to five hours of practical
work outside of class every week.
There are a lot of design school courses
which are very popular amongst the GSB
students, which are all hands-on.
There are a few courses
which involve fieldwork
that are definitely global experience
problems which count as a coursework.
But it is like, basically,
going to a different country
with a bunch of your classmates.
>> Yeah.
>> So
it's an interesting mix of both,
I would say.
>> Great.
The next question we'll take is,
what clubs and
activities outside of
class are you enrolled in?
>> I'll go.
>> When you have free time.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I'm involved in a couple of things.
I am part of Students Association.
I work in career committee and
international committee,
because these are the two things
which are kind of dear to me.
I am really passionate about
ensuring international students
get all the required resources to pursue
the careers that they wanted to pursue.
And like I mentioned,
I also came to GSB with a goal of
transition into tech product management.
So I got involved in
Tech Club very earlier on.
I believe there's a [INAUDIBLE] Tech Club.
Yeah, I also sit on the senate where
a lot of important discussions and
decisions are made.
So I would say all these experiences
have enriched by GSB life so far.
>> And you can keep busy, for sure.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, for me, it's very similar.
I co-chair the academic committee here and
also sit on the senate of
the student association with.
I am deeply interested in
businesses in India, and
I'm the President for
the Business in India club here.
In addition, I'm also involved
in a committee called Future of
Management Education,
in which we are holistically looking at
what are the different ways in which we
can basically cater to the MBA program
here and make it even more attractive for
students going forward.
>> Okay, great.
The next question, how has your proximity
to Silicon Valley benefitted you compared
to other programs not in the Bay Area?
>> I think the biggest benefit for
me is the proximity
to all the protagonists of the cases
that we do in the classes.
All the classes which cover technology and
entrepreneurship have
cases surrounding real life
protagonists who live right
outside Stanford,
like in Palo Alto and Mountain View.
So it's very easy to have
access to people like that.
So every single day,
in each of my classes, I have one of these
people who have taken a company public or
have achieved several other great things
in the technology space,
venture capitalists come and talk to us,
which is something I can't imagine
happening as easily in other schools.
Secondly, being one of
the leaders of the Tech Club,
I can totally see how it benefits us
in the way of networking as well.
It’s so easy for us to call anybody out
and ask them to come out and do a BBL,
which is a brown bag lunch or lunchtime
session, where they come and talk about
topic of their interest or just represent
the company that wants to hire from GSB.
So I think these are the two benefits
which I can very obviously see how
it benefits Stanford or any other school.
>> Yeah, and just in terms of access
to protagonists on the cases,
it's also proximity to
the culture of Silicon Valley.
I think this is a culture which
sort of celebrates taking risks,
being entrepreneurial,
going after what seems impossible.
And just being in that environment sort
of, especially for risk-averse people like
me, sort of encourages you to go think
outside the box, go achieve your dream.
And so I think it tells us a good
mental lab to put yourself through.
>> Good, great, all right.
What was the application and
admissions process like from
your perspective as a student?
>> I think, for me,
the application process was, in a way,
great mental journey to go through.
Because the application process sort of
encouraged me to think deeply about what
matters to me and
what defines me as a person.
And I think this a culture which
is like a vastly celebrated, or
a GSB of knowing yourself well.
And the application
process sort of encourages
each one of us to sort of go
through that mental journey.
And it was also interesting to get
a chance to interview with an alumni and
share their experiences,
what they valued at the GSB.
So I think it's a good mix
of getting to know yourself,
getting to know GSB from
different diverse perspectives.
So it was a good reflection of
the GSB culture in general.
>> Yeah, we talk about
the journey here at the GSB, but
it really starts in
the application process, yeah.
Do you have anything you
want to add to that?
>> Yeah, I strongly agree with what
said about it being a mental journey.
It's a deep personal experience.
I don't think any other school's
application essay would probe you to think
as much as yourself as much
as the Stanford essay does.
When I started writing my response
to what matters to most to
you and why, it really prompted me
to think about my entire life and
pick out instances that
really matter to me.
And that journey really extended when
I came to GSB, like I gave a talk.
It was like an extension of that.
So it’s really interesting how
the journey which started,
what matters to you most and
why, keeps getting iterated and
improved upon through several
other experiences at GSP.
>> Yeah, a deeply introspective
process that continues, even here.
>> Yeah.
[LAUGH]
>> How did you select the person
who wrote your recommendation letter?
>> I think it was kind of obvious for me.
Because I selected my immediate manager,
and his manager,
the two people who had the best view to
my work, because that was my first job.
I haven't really spent
time in any other company.
I joined Unilever right out of college and
spent all my time there.
And my first boss saw me go
through being a first time
manager to finishing off
a stint of two years properly.
So he was the best person,
position to write about me.
And similarly, his manager also had
good view to what happened through
my career at Unilever, so these are the
two people who were my obvious choices.
>> Yeah, I'll go to you too, but
I want to add to what you said,
which another question is who
should applicants choose.
And I think it's important that as
you are considering individuals,
that you do look to those who
know you most well, right?
So those who have had
the closest experience and
can speak specifically to things that
you have done, what you've accomplished.
And so it's more important that you
find someone who knows you well and
can write on that behalf.
What do you want to share?
>> I think you covered it mostly.
I would just encourage you to take
the recommendations of someone who knows
you well and can talk specific examples.
Because that is something that
the admission officer appreciates.
Some tangible examples of
the qualities they are highlighting in
the recommendation letter.
>> Yeah, and
we do have requirements, of course,
that you would want to select your
immediate direct current supervisor,
unless there is a reason that
you are unable to do so.
What is student life like at the GSB and
is it easy to blend in with the people?
>> I think GSB people are some of
the easiest people to blend in with
because everybody comes in with an aim to
get to know other people in the class.
And because we all care deeply about
introspection and self-awareness,
people are very grounded and
people really care about knowing where you
come from than sort of just at
the superficial details of your resume.
So I think there are a lot
of opportunities to
meet a lot of interesting people.
I felt at home right away.
>> Yeah.
>> I think very similar.
I think this is a culture that sort
of celebrates the differences and
sort of encourages you to be yourself.
And I think one common phrase that we use
here is, fitting in and standing out.
And I think both are equally
celebrated here.
There are a lot of things
that we share as a class.
And in that sense, we fit in.
But we also celebrate standing out,
because each one of us bring
a different thing to the class.
And that is something that we
as a community appreciate,
want to develop further.
So it's not a pressure to just fit in, but
also stand out in your own unique way.
>> Very good, great.
What should one focus on when
they start attending Stanford?
So preparation-wise, so to speak,
how do you decide what classes and
experiences to take advantage of?
>> So I can start on this one.
It sort of goes back to the point that
it's really important that you have two or
three broad goals for
yourself when you come to Stanford.
When you come here, there will be
literally millions of opportunities and
you would want to be a part of dance show,
you would want to be part of this club and
this certain activity.
For me, in the first week when I came
to Stanford, I made a list of like,
these are the three things I want
to walk away out of Stanford.
And every activity I
sort of try to do here,
I use this lens to evaluate whether
it makes sense for me personally.
And it is just good to keep a center and
be honest to yourself, so
that when you are done with the two years,
you feel proud of what you have done here.
>> Yeah, that should be done.
I often hear people say it's like
drinking out of a water hose.
>> [LAUGH]
>> There's so many options and
opportunties to get involved.
It is helpful to sort of have
a little bit of an idea or
a focus but also be open to other options.
>> Absolutely.
>> Plus one.
>> Okay, all right.
Have you taken any classes
outside of the GSB?
>> I did a couple in my first year.
I did a couple of class in
the computer science department, and
I also did a really extensive
design school class.
Both were very unique experiences,
nothing like GSB.
A lot of fun getting to
know people outside of GSB.
It's called across-the-street classes, and
it's a great way to get out of the GSB
bubble, especially in the first year.
>> Yeah.
>> Where you live in a dorm right across
your classroom complex, so
it's one way to really get out there and
meet other interesting people in
the broader Stanford community.
>> Taking classes,
I'll say GSB is like a very unique
value proposition that Stanford has.
Just the proximity and the relationship
GSB shares with other school
within the Stanford family, just gives
you a lot of different perspectives and
helps you basically your
network beyond GSB.
I took a really interesting class,
Public Speaking Across the Street,
which was very unique and very different
from the classes we do at the GSB,
so it's a great resource that
is available to GSB students.
>> Yeah, and
they're talking about across the street,
which of course is our term that
we use for really any of the other
leading professional graduate schools
on campus that you'll have access to.
You can literally walk within 10 or
15 minutes and
be at some of these other
professional schools on campus.
And it is why over 90% of our students
will take a course across the street.
So it's a big part of your experience.
What is the professional background
of your peers at the GSB?
Are they diverse in industry and
experience?
I think we touched a little bit on the
importance of diversity within the class.
But anything to elaborate on?
>> Yeah, I think in terms of professional
diversity, this is as wide as it gets.
There are people from consulting, private
equity, to military, to operations.
I have one of my classmates
who was a NASCAR racedriver.
So it's like diversity in
terms of as broad as it gets.
And the way it sort of shows up and
is helpful in the classroom is your
professional background shapes the way you
look at different business problems or
non-business problems.
And just having that diversity encourages
you to think in many different ways
to a problem which you wouldn't
have thought of otherwise.
So I think it's as diverse
as it can politically get.
>> Yeah, totally agree with that.
And not to mention the number of
Colombians we have in our class.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I think this diversity's really
helpful in helping you with your
own career pursuits, I think.
Because if you want to make a switch from
one industry to a different industry,
there are already a few people who
have done that before coming to GSB.
So you can just grab a coffee with them
and understand what that industry's all
about or what that particular
function is all about.
>> Yep.
>> And get some key contacts which will
help you make inroads into that new career
that you want to pursue.
And people are so
willing to help here all the time,
that everybody is just a phone call or
a text message away.
So this diversity can really be
leveraged to follow your passions.
>> Great, thank you.
When is the right time to apply to
the GSB and which round is best?
So I talked a little bit about the right
time to apply is when you are ready.
That could mean right when
you graduate from college.
It could mean that you want two, three,
five, ten years of working experience.
From our perspective, and
in the admissions office,
when you decide to apply is Not
necessarily important to us,
but it's important for
us to understand why it is now.
One of the other questions was
about which round is fast,
in general it is preferred to
apply in round one or round two,
there are certain opportunities
that we provide as a result.
If you are a round one or round two
applicant we offer admit weekend, so
you have the opportunity to come
here on campus if at all possible,
there are other access that
you'll have available to you.
But we certainly want you to
apply when you're ready, so
if that means waiting until
round three that's fine as well.
Not sure if you guys have any perspective,
having gone through the application
yourself, the process.
>> I think you got it well, and
I would encourage you to not worry too
much about round one versus round two.
Round three is something that, as I said,
should only be used in
extraordinary circumstances.
But between round one and round two,
I would not put a lot of maths behind it,
whenever you are ready and
you think it's the best time and
what round's best for you.
>> Okay, all right, what is the Reliance
Fellowship and what are the requirements?
So I touched on this a little bit,
which is that we do offer a fellowship for
those individuals who live in India and
have a desire to return to
India after graduating.
There are specific requirements,
you can go online to our website and
learn more about that under
our fellowship opportunities.
Do you have any classmates
who you happen to know, or
of course do you want to speak to?
>> For sure, so the process to apply for
this fellowship is to
actually it begins before any of
the GSB application process starts.
It starts with an essay that you have to
write about what are your aspirations for
India, how do you want to see
India shape up in the near future?
Based on that essay and
your resume you will be short-listed,
a bunch of 50 students is short-listed?
>> Yeah, 50 finalists.
>> And there is a networking session which
is organized towards the end of August,
I think, where you'll meet with
several Stanford admissions or staff,
as well as several alumni based in India.
There are a couple of group activities and
a lot of interaction with Stanford
alumni and fellow applicants.
And once you do that, you apply along
with everybody else in round one or
round two, depend.
When I applied to it I could only apply
in round one, but it has been flexed
last year and now you can apply
either in round one or round two.
Normal application process there's nothing
different about the Stanford application
process, the only additional step is
the essay which you have to submit
around mid-July and the networking
session that I just talked about.
And these 50 finalists will apply like any
other regular Stanford applicant in either
round one or round two.
>> Yeah, and so is talking about
the pre-application process,
which is what you would
do in the early summer.
And then we also offer a Reliance
finalists day where we bring in everyone
to learn a little bit more about the MBA
program and the GSB experience, and
give you the opportunity to meet
alumni of the program as well.
And then the second part of
the process is for you to apply,
just like any other candidate, through
the general MBA application process and
we'd evaluate you as such.
>> Yes.
>> What career networking and
other professional opportunities
have you been able to take
advantage of while at the GSB?
>> So
I think in terms of career opportunities,
this is an ocean of opportunities.
I know classmates who have been
trying to switch either industries,
geographies, or function, and
I think there are opportunities available
through various different resources.
One is the Career Management Services,
the CMC as we call it here, and
they organize workshops,
special workshops for
international students on how does
American style of interviewing happens.
They have company networking nights,
where companies from
all sorts of different industries come and
you can interact with them.
And they also have on campus
a recruitment process.
In terms of networking,
it goes beyond just the CMC.
And as alluded to there
are brown bag lunches, and
what we call BBLs hosted by different
companies all throughout the year.
And that's a good way to one
appreciate what these companies do and
also get to know the professionals there,
be in touch with them,
learn from them over there, and
not just during the recruitment season.
And in terms of
professional opportunities,
there are a lot of activities that
go on from interviewing skills,
to building your resume, to actually
figuring out what career is best for you.
So I remember some of the workshops in
the beginning of the year which were super
helpful in terms of just thinking
through what sort of career would help
you find the most meaning in your life.
>> Yeah.
>> So I think it's a really vast
ocean of opportunities, and
it ranges from very philosophical
to very tactical opportunities.
>> Yeah, so
plus one to everything he said.
Apart from that, a little bit of
detail about how the networking and
recruitment happens here.
So there are two ways, like alluded to,
one is the on-campus recruitment
way which kind of gets by January and
mid February and you have.
>> So the traditional track, yeah.
>> Yeah it's the very traditional kind
of companies that come on campus.
Then there is a networking
based job search which happens
later in the winter quarter and
through your spring quarter.
One unique thing about Stanford is that
lot of people, especially for internships,
really want to pursue new things, so they
tend to prefer network-based job search.
And what exactly helps
network-based job search?
There are two different avenues that
I can think of, one is the clubs.
A lot of these companies approach clubs
and the clubs conduct the BVOs that
was talking about, that's a great way to
network and apply to these companies.
And then CMC also has a lot
of alumni information,
you just need to figure out what
companies you're interested in.
There are career advisers that will help
you figure out how to approach the company
and who are the right people that you
need to contact in those companies.
And the third, sometimes use
resources are professors I would say,
a lot of our professors
are practitioners in industry.
They all either operate companies
currently, or they have operated
companies in the past so they are also
very well connected in the industries.
So in first year, slightly difficult
to get access to those professors because
a lot of them teach in the second year.
But still it can be done
because nobody is going to deny
helping you if you reach out to them,
you just need to know who to reach out to.
So professors are kind of slightly
underrated, but a very useful resource.
>> I want to touch a little bit on,
there are of course a lot of resources as
you mentioned, and also there is the AAP,
the academic adjustment period,
which begins in your first quarter.
So how did that affect your, or tell
us a little bit about that experience,
sort of that time that you
can not have to worry so
much about the career trajectory.
>> Sure, so academic adjustment
period is the first six weeks
when you get in the GSB.
And I think it’s a really important
period because when you come in here most
of you would be moving to the US Most
likely for the first time,
you will be living in the US.
You'll be meeting a set of new friends,
new classmates,
getting to settle in a new
educational environment.
So this basically six weeks provide
a buffer where you are not exposed to any
career activities or any club activities.
And you can just focus on
settling into the system,
get to know your classmates well, spend
some time socially, and things like that.
So I think for me, personally,
AB was a great time to just make
myself comfortable in the system
before the floodgates open, and
you start including or joining the clubs.
>> Yeah, thank you.
[LAUGH] Thanks.
All right, well we're coming
to the close of our webinar.
But before we go, do either of you
have any final words of advice?
I'll start with you, Shusmita.
>> I think when I applied to GSB,
I had a very
one-dimensional approach to it,
like I want to switch my careers.
But I think a GSB experience
is a lot more than that.
It's a lot about knowing yourself better,
and becoming a better person.
I'm not just throwing some
corny lines out there.
It's really true.
There are so many experiences like talk
at GP Lee and a bunch of other courses.
Just the community around you which
really helps you understand yourself and
be a better version of yourself.
And I'm totally having a lot of fun.
I would do it all over again if I have to.
>> Yeah, thank you.
>> So for me, it's very similar.
One little addition I had here is
basically technical skills and article
skills are simply hygiene as you think of
leadership roles and interpersonal skills.
And how you lead teams is
basically what differentiates you
as you grow up the corporate ladder.
And I think GSB just provides you that
lab where you can experiment with
different styles of your leadership or
how you interact with people.
And I think that journey is
such invaluable resource that
you will be thankful for
it for the rest of your life.
>> That's great, great advice,
both of you, thank you.
Thank you both for
joining us, and thanks for
all of you out there
who were participating.
You can learn more about the Stanford MBA
program on our website and
by watching our videos on YouTube.
[MUSIC]